はい それではよろしくお願いします
で まず今日のテーマについて
まあできるだけ早い言葉でさっさとお話をさせていただきます
テーマっていうのは 誰にも奪われない幸福ということで
副題はブッダに学び 明るい日本語を築きましょうというふうにありますけどもね
これは私の管轄外なので
それについては喋りません
で 誰にも奪われない幸福ということで
あまり難しいことではなくて
とてもとても一般的な常識的なところで理解できると思いますね
で まずは幸福 幸福というんですけどね
何があれば幸福ですかと
それはとても問題なんですね
まあ一般的に考えるのはね
財産 知識 美容 権力などがあれば幸福やと思っている人々もいますね
まあそれは人によって違いますけど
金さえあれば幸福だとかね
よく知識があれば勉強できれば幸福だというふうに
美しく生まれれば大丈夫やとか
とにかく権力を得た他というふうに
まあ人によってそれぞれ違いますけどね
また ごく一般的なね 家族
親族 友人などなどいれば幸福ではないかなと思う人々もいるんですね
また 仕事があれば幸福やと思っている人
能力を上げればね あるいは技能
技術的にね 自分が腕が上がったらそれこそ幸福だと期待しているんだという思う人もいるでしょうし
まあまた健康長寿を願っている人々もいますね
自分にとって幸福とは健康であること
長寿であることというふうに思う人もいるんですね
はい 次の問題になるのは
ではどの程度であれば良いのでしょうかということなんですね
我々は色々ことをね これが幸福
これが幸福やと思ってはいるんですけど
はい それは構わない 金があれば私は幸福やというならば
それは一向に構わない
次の問題は 金どれくらいあればあなたは幸福だと思いますか？ということなんです
あるいは健康でいれば私は幸せやと
健康というのはどの程度のものかと
どの程度の健康になれば幸せですか？というこの程度が必要なんですね
で そこで私が言ってないんだけど
我々は知識があれば 財産があれば幸福だと言ってますけど
上限はないんですね 上限がないと
いくら頑張っても頑張っても苦労ばっかりでしょうね
この山を登りますと言えば
山には頂上があるんでしょ
だから山を登るのはいくら苦しくても
頂上に達したらすごい気分がいいんです
この山を登りますと言っても
頂上がなければどうするんですかね
だから我々は一般的に
この頂上が成り立たない
見当たらない山を登っていますよ
財産があれば お金があれば幸せやと言っても
これどこまでやればということはないんだから
それだったら一向に幸せになれっこはないんですね
美しくいれば幸せやと思ったっても
どの程度かいと その上限がないと
これは幸福の目的にすることはできません
なぜならば それ自体がその人はクタクタいじめられるんです
上限なく金儲けると もうどうなるんですかね
鬼のように金儲けて 奴隷のように死ぬだけでしょ
幸福にならない だからまあみんなこのスポーツする人々でもね
最高なスポーツマンであっても
まあオリンピックで金メダル取りたいと思ってるでしょうね
それで金メダル取ったところで
その人が幸せを感じますよ
やったよと そこで何か条件があるんですね
そういうわけで 条件が必要なんですね
まず我々は上限がなく幸せの目的を考えている
次の問題は これは依存することなんですね
家族がいれば幸せだというと
家族に依存している いっぱい知識があれば
知識人であれば 私は幸せだというならば
その人は知識に依存している
頑張って国会議員にもなれれば幸せやと言ったら
その人は権力に依存している
この依存とは病気です
それははっきりしてほしいんです
依存というのは何であろうとも病気です
依存という言葉を使っちゃうと
この病みつきになるんですよ
それがなくなると大変なことになるんです
だから この何のことないことであっても
依存しちゃうと病気なんですよ
例えば子供はゲームやるのは一向に構わない
当たり前のことですけど
ゲーム機を離す 離れることから離すことは全くできなくなってくると
これがすごい病気なんです
その気になったらもうゲームをやって
すぐ嫌になったらやめちゃって
また別なことをやったりする場合は依存していないんですね
勉強する時でも ご飯食べる時でも
ゲーム機が頭から離れないと
これ依存なんですね これはやっぱり治療しなくちゃいけない大変な病気になるんです
だから我々は たとえ小さなことであっても
依存することは気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
それで一番悪いことは
この幸福依存なんですけど
幸福だと物に依存することを考えていると
これがすごい悪いし それから上限がないんですね
だから一向に苦しみだけなんですよ
例えばある人がまあ 500 万の貯金できれば
もう私が幸せやと思ったら
まあなんとかして 500 万ぐらい貯金できるでしょ
昼も夜もパートやって
これで 500 万円  500円と言ったっけ
500万円貯金になったら
本人がなんかすごい楽しいんですよ
やったんだと だからこの上限をつけなくちゃいけないのに
我々は上限をつけたとしても依存していますね
だから依存は病気です
はい これが私は勝手な名前を付けちゃって
刺激依存症と これ 専門家が言っている言葉ではないんです
この我々は何を考えているのかというと
はっきりこれから仏教の中身に入って考えましょう
我々にはこの眼耳鼻舌身意という認識する器官が 6つありますね
それに色声香味触法 という情報が入るんですね
入ると心に入って刺激を与えるんです
目で物を見ると 頭に刺激が入るんですよ
耳で音を聞くと頭に刺激が入るんですよ
刺激を与えてくれる財産
家族などに執着している
それが幸福だと誤解する
だから家族がいると 目から耳から体からあらゆる刺激が入るんですね
家族から そこで この刺激を与えてくれる家族に対して執着する
例えば花束を見たら なんてきれいでしょうかと
それで刺激を受けているんですね
それで花束を大事に持っていって
壁にでも飾って置いておくんですね
そこを誰かが潰しちゃったら
捨てたら結構困ります
怒ります 何するのかと
だから楽しみを与えてくれるものに執着します
だから物が幸福だと誤解するんですね
子供はボールで遊んでいると
子供にとっては楽しいんですね
それで子供がボールが幸福を与えてくれるんだというふうに思ってしまうんです
ボールは何も与えてくれてないんですよ
ボールを蹴ったり取ったり
投げたり いろんなことをしていると
なんか心が楽しくなってくるんですね
これで楽しみが作ってくる原因は
このボールだと一緒にする
そこでボールが割れたら
壊れたら 誰かに持っていかれたら
まあ大変なことになって泣く羽目になっちゃいますね
人は刺激を与えてくれる品物を必死で探し求めています
人々っていうのはそういうことで
何を探すのかというと
本当は幸福を探してないんです
品物を探しているんです
ものすごい苦労しながら品物を探しているんです
この品物といったら ちょっとわかりにくくて幅広いんだから
お釈迦様は色声香味触法にしているんです
科学的に 例えば 大型のテレビが欲しいと思う
で 我々はその場合は見るものと聞くものですね
探しているのは これ 見るものは派手に見たいし
聞くものも派手に聞きたい
だから大型テレビが欲しくなるんですね
で 家の家具として見たら
小さい方がいいやとわかってますけど
めんどくさいと しかし
見るもの 聞くものに ですから
テレビ買う場合はできるだけ大きいものを買おうとする
なぜできるだけ大きいものを買うするのかというと
目から入る刺激と耳から入る刺激をできるだけ派手にしたいんですね
だから 人から朝から晩まで若者が頑張って金を貯めて大型テレビ買おうと頑張ってますですね
だから これは品物を探しているんですね
品物に幸福があると思っているんですね
はい そういうことで よく考えてみると
我々は幸福は何なのかもわからなくて
品物を探しているんだから
困ったことに人生は赤字
赤字になっているのです
刺激の対象は生まれとともについてこない
生まれる時は見るものも聞くものも何もついてこないんですね
知識 財産 家族 友人 権力
地位などを獲得しなくてはいけないんですね
生まれたら何もないんです
生まれてから大きくなる時にも何もないんですよ
だからこの品物を獲得しなくちゃあかんですよ
獲得に成功しても 逃げられないように守らなくてはならない
だからみんな成功するわけじゃないんです
ある人が ある子供が知識欲しいと
頭がいい人間になりたいと思って必死で勉強するかもしれませんだけど
うまくいくかないかようわからないんですね
じゃあ子供の期待通りに
よく勉強できる頭の良い人になったとしましょう
しかし 知識っていうのは自分からずっと逃げていくんですね
それから ある人がいっぱい金持ちになりたいと思って勉強して
仕事をして 商売に手を出して頑張りますね
それで成功するかしないかはわかりませんだけど
もし成功したならば その時点からその人
この金を金が自分から逃げるんですよ
だから あれこれと工夫して
金が自分の手元に留まる
留まるようにと すごく必死で頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
これ大変ですよ もしかすると金儲かりよりも金が止めてもらうことが大変かもしれません
刺激対象は希望期待通りにならない
次のポイントは 刺激対象っていうのは
お金やら財産やら知識などなどでしょう
これが欲しい欲しいと思っても
そううまくはいかないんです
だから我々はこれぐらい金あればこうなれば
こんな家作れ作れればとかね
いろんな希望はしますよ
期待もします 勉強する若者は一流の大学に入りたいとかね
アメリカの大学で留学したいとか
いろいろ期待 希望はあるかもしれませんだけど
そう簡単にはいくわけじゃないんですね
そこで苦しいんですよ
一流の大学に入って勉強してからアメリカ大学の留学したいと思ったら
まあそれはずるずると簡単にいくわけじゃないんです
かなり苦しい道を歩まなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで期待 希望が上がれば上がるほど
生きる苦しみが増えちゃうんです
これって幸せですか？と
だからアメリカに留学したいんだけど
どこか田舎の辺鄙なところの学校でもいいやと思ったら
期待はあまり高くないんですね
で アメリカの辺鄙なところの大学だったらね
もうまあ何もできなくても入れてくれるんです
入学金だけ払ってくださいと
それでまあ それうろうろしていれば
後で卒業もできます しかし
一流の大学に入りたいと思ったら
イェールに入りたいと思ったら
これちょっと大変です
だからイェール大学に入るのはもう期待がすごく高いんですし
希望が高いんだけど その分かなり苦しいんですよ
そんな簡単に入れてくれませんね
その場合 ハードルが高い
だから希望が期待が高く高ければ
そこを目指して頑張ることはの苦しみが多く大きくなるんです
はい これはこの刺激の世界の生き方なんですね
だから皆様がやってないんだけど
お釈迦様は計算していますよ
わずかな楽しみのために限りのない悩み
苦しみを軽減するんです
これ ちゃんとしたまあ決算なんです
例えば 相手が誰でもいいんだけど
結婚したいと思ったら
それほどハードルが高くないんですね
まあ手に入ります しかし
相手が美しくて 痩せていて
まあ料理が料理が上手で
知識人で あれやこれやとかね
金もあってとか まあいろいろ希望を上げて上げて上げてみてください
大変なことになるんですよ
そういうことで 人生っていうのは本当は赤字です
これが幸福と言えるのかと
無常は絶対的な真理 一切の現象は無常だからこそ成り立っています
なんかいきなりテーマが変わっちゃったんです
何やこれはと思うでしょ
で 私は人生は赤字だと言ってから
それでも我々は赤字だと認めていないでしょう
誰でも赤字ですよ 日本の総理大臣であろうとも
ホームレスの方であろうとも
人生は赤字ですよ で 我々は気にしていないんですね
結構うまくやってるんだと
吾輩は幸せやと思っているんです
はい それでこの幸せであるものにはものすごく執着するんです
例えば お母さんが子供が 2人ぐらいいれば
まあ幸せなこと 幸せであること
子供が可愛くて 子供を育てることは楽しくて幸せを感じますよ
ですから 子供にぐっと執着するんで
これでまた滑るんです
人生は 赤字の人生なのに
それも気づいていない
その上滑るんです どこで滑るかと
我が子っていうのはいない
これは矛盾ですよ 執着したっても意味がないんです
すべては無常で常に変化するからこそ
我々は生きているんです
無常っていうのは大事なことなんです
別に大事にどうでもいいんです
無常は真理です 誰にもどうすることもできない
無常だから私は生きています
別に無常様ありがとうございますと言わなくたってもいいんです
で 神のおかげで生きているという場合は
神に感謝しなくちゃあかんでしょ
でも神っていうのは存在しないし
我々は無常というものがあって生きているんです
しかし 無常様感謝しますとは言いません
地球は自転するのも もう宇宙があるのも
我々食べたご飯 消化するのも
消化したものは体にエネルギーになるのも
ただ この講演 私の声が聞いて理解することも無常のプロセスなんですよ
無常でなければ何も成り立たないんです
愚者は都合の悪いものは早く消えてほしい
都合の良いものはそのまま変わらないでほしいと切望しますね
そこで滑るんです 無常で生きているのに
無常だから生きているのに
生きていることはそのまま無常なのに
例えば音楽を聴いていると楽しいでしょう
音楽が流れて消えていけない
消えてやらないと音楽にならないんですよ
音が現れては消える 現れては消える
だから様々な音になるんですよ
一つの音が出た瞬間 その音はずっとあるんだったらどうしますかね？死んじゃいますよ
例えばこのホールで誰かがピアノでドって音を出す
それからその音が消えないで
ホールがある限りその音を聞けるんだったらどうしますかね
これで終わりでしょうに
もうホールは二度と使えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから音楽があるっていうことは無常だからあるんです
子供が可愛いっていうことは
無常だから可愛いなんです
しかし 私たちはもう相当脱線して滑ってます
無常はないがしろにするんです
なんか地球に引力がないんだよというようなことなんです
誰が気にする？気にするのかと
地球のジーフォースはと
そんなことを言ったっても
ジーフォースのおかげで全部やってるんでしょうに
だから愚かなもんなことなんですね
そこで愚者は都合の悪いものだけ消えてほしい
都合の良いものはそのまま変わらないでほしいと絶望する
だからお母さんが可愛い我が子がずっとそのままいてほしいと思うでしょ
これで困りますね だって子供が変わるんだから
出ていくんだから いくら頑張って育てても
何人間になるかわからないでしょう
良い人間になるかもしれませんし
親を殺す人間になるかもしれません
かもしれませんし しかし
執着しちゃうんですね
そんなはずではなかったと言うでしょ
なんであんな言葉が来るんですかね
そんなはずではなかったと
何者ですかね あなたは
世界は無常だから はずは成り立たないんですよ
智者は無常ならざるものはありえないと知る
で 愚者のと智者の差なんですね
だから愚者がすごく苦しくなるんです
自分の都合のいいものは残れるわけないでしょう
この楽しみは永久的に
この幸せは永久的にとか
こんなのはないんです
それで悪いものは早く消えて消えてちょうだいと
無常には勝てませんよ
だから智者は放っておくんです
悪いものになったって
まあいいやと 幸せを感じたって
まあいいやと まあそのうち消えますよと
悪いことが都合の悪いこと
まあいいや そのうち消えますよということでほっとするんですね
はい 次に行きます 刺激依存型の幸福
この写真で出ています
刺激依存型はどんな幸福を感じるのかと
一 財産 子孫 知識 権力 若さ
美等々は必ず自分から離れていく
二 災害などで消えていく
見えますかね 三 嫌な人に奪われる
四 そうならないように虚しく努力するが
それは不安と苦しみを作り出す
だから 一 二 三にやられないように頑張ってますよ
みんな 災害で損害を受けないようにと頑張っていますけど
あの頑張ること自体も苦しいんですよ
泥棒が入らないようにと頑張るのも構わないんだけど
それ自体苦しいんです
怖いんです 不安です どうにもならん
金儲けて家に置いておいたっても消えてしまう
これが苦しい 消えないように守ろうとすると
それまた苦しい 五 何も起きなくても無常なので
瞬間瞬間幸福の対象は消えていく
では ある人には一も二も三も四も
の苦しみもなかったとしましょう
それでも五はどうですか？と
幸福は消えていくんですね
はい なんか変なテーマですけどね
幸せの居場所なんですね
まあまあ説明したと思います
どこに幸せがありますかと
まあ簡単にね ごちそうを見せると幸せを感じる
では 大量の食べ物の中に自分を放り投げたら何を感じるでしょうかと
例えば ある人がなんかすごいごちそうを見ると
ああ 幸せだなと その人は愚痴の中に放り込むんです
どうなるんですか そのまま幸せを与えるものは幸せを与えるのではなく
そのものに関する自分の気持ち
愛着 感情が幸せだと理解するんです
例えばね 泳ぎたいと プールに飛び込みたいと一人が待っている
もう一人が  そんな気持ちも何もなく待っている
そこでプールに飛び込みたい人はプールに飛び込んで楽しいでしょ
その気持ちがない人を蹴っ飛ばしちゃえば同じことでしょ
その人は幸せを感じないんです
同じことでしょ 二人の人がプールにある
ちょっと高く上げている台に立っています
一人がプールに飛び込み飛び込みたくて待ってます
一人はただ立ってるだけ
そこで飛び込みたい人を押しても
その人は飛び込んで気持ちいい
飛び込みたくない人は蹴っ飛ばしちゃえばプールに落ちますけど
幸せなところが腹が立ってるんですね
何するのかと 危ないんではないかと
危ないんだったら 前の人飛び込んだでしょうに
だから客観的に言えば
二人の人間が同じ経験を味わっているのに
一人が幸せ 一人が腹が立っているなんです
それでわかりますかね？幸せって何ですか？と
どこにあるんですかね
プールは幸せを与えてくれないんですよ
プールは幸せを与えてくれるならば
プールに飛ぶ誰でも幸せになるはずなんです
それで幸福の住所わかりますかね
外にあるものに 例えばプールに対して愛着がないと
プールに飛び込んで楽しくないんです
今日はもうプールにも入りたくないと思っている人にとっては
その日はプールに対して愛着がないんです
で ごちそうを見て幸せを感じるのは
ああ ごちそうを食べたいと思っている人なんです
愛着が必要です 例えば皆様の目の前で
ちょっと生肉一部をね
ぶら下がってどうですか？とかね
言ったって皆様気持ち悪くて下がるんです
これは猫の前に 犬の前にぶら下がっちゃうと
もう愛着があって食べようとする
犬だったら尾っぽを振ったり
はい お座りと言ったら座って座ったりして
お手と言ったら手まで出して
言うことを何でもやる
で 生の肉をそのままパクッと食べて
犬が幸せを感じる だから犬に肉に対して愛着があるんです
肉の中に幸せは住んでいるわけじゃないんですね
だからお金 知識 権力 家族
建物 財産 名誉 あれやこれや
そういうものの中に幸せがいないんです
幸せは愛着にあるんですね
感情にあるんです 欲しいという
はい そこで愛着はとんでもないものだとお釈迦様もおっしゃっていますけど
それはちょっとカットして
したがって幸福とは心の状態
それだけ覚えておいてください
幸福っていうのは 自分の心の問題なんです
脳の問題なんです 世界の外の問題じゃないんですよ
だから明るい日本を築きましょうやとね
あれは私から見れば成り立たん
何があったっても泣くやつらは泣くんだからね
いくらあったっても文句言う人は文句言うんだからね
政治家と同じなんですよ
何やっても文句言う そういうことで
幸せっていうのは心の問題なんです
別に日本の中でね 新しい家を作ったりとかね
トンネルを掘ったりとかね
そんなことなくたっても
今から幸せを感じようと思ったら
もう日本全国は幸福になるんです
いたって簡単です で 心の
問題なんです はい 次に心に入ります
またなくなった なんて
あ こちら回すか 怪しいものが終わりました
心っていうのは心に幸せが宿るんだけど
これ揺らぐんですよ 大変なことになる
あの 活断層の上で手抜きして原発作ったような感じなんです
日本では原発を作る時はね
あの断層を探していくんだからね
で まあ 家を作ったって
もう土台が揺らぐんだったら家が潰れるでしょう
だから心は揺らぐんですね
もうタンポポのように
なかなかこのまま美しくいるっていうことは絶対ありえないんです
ちょっとしたことでもう終わり
財産等々があると幸福を感じますが
それはなくなると自分の期待通りにならないと悩み
悲しみ 不安 不満 落ち込みなどが襲うんです
で 勘違いして生きている我々は
この物に幸せがあると思っている
有名な画家の絵画買うことができれば幸せだと
すごい金かけていろんな面白い人は全然面白くない
高価なグッズを集める人々いるでしょ？絵画集めるは
非常に珍しいガラクタを集めるはとかね
あれはもう億単位なんですね
値段は 何の価値もないんだけどね
私から見立て見たら モナリザってどんな価値があるんですかね
別にようわからないんですよ
昔のじじいが描いた絵でしょ
残っているのは それは構わないと
まあだから古いものを保存するのは当たり前だから
まあそれなりに保存して置いておけばいいでしょうに
あれほど警備って何なのかと
ただ大した絵でもないし
そんな腰が抜けるほどの
ようわからないんで 私は正直なところ
ただ慣れているだけなん見たら
それで最近ね なんか最近ニュースになりましたけど
もう一つコピー見つけちゃってね
で これはオリジナルかないかという疑問があってね
で もっと若いモナリザですね
それもオリジナルであると断定したんだと
勝手にしろよと 別に で
とにかくモナリザがなくなったら
フランス国民はどんな気持ちになるんですかね
あれ フランスにあるんでしたっけ？知らないですよ
おそらくフランス美術館でしたっけね
でまあ そんなもんなんですね
日本でもね すごい あの西洋の画家のね
高いお金を払っていろいろ買ってあったんですけど
バブルの時期とかね 今は誰も買わないんだけど
もしなくなったらね 大変ですよ
そこで例えば億の絵画がなくなったんだ
なくなりましたと  5億円消えましたと言ったら
それは嘘です  5億円で絵画買ったら
もう 5億円なくなってますよ
絵画が残っているんです
それには大した価値はないんです
それがなくなったら 5
億円もなくなったと言ったって
なくなって 5億円なくなってないんです
とっくになくなっていたんですけど
まあ何かなくなったんですね
それで悩み 悲しみ 苦しみが襲ってくるんですね
財産等々がなくなっても
勝手に変化しても 心で感じる幸福はそのまま保つことができるのでしょうかと
はい 例えば日本でなんかひまわりとかなんとかとかね
絵画がありますからね
で またたくさんありますけど
私はおんちですからね
もう知らないだけで 私は海外ではね
おにぎり 1個あればありがたいと思ってますからね
じゃあもっと我々の世界から話しましょうかね
ある女性がね 自分の相手からね
500万円ぐらいの価値のあるダイヤの指輪をもらう
婚約指輪でしたっけ これ
ダイヤがちょっと虫眼鏡なくても見えるんです
だから 500万なんです
で 虫眼鏡なくても見えるダイヤがついている指輪をもらって
えらい幸せ感じるでしょ
その女性は にっこにこと笑って踊って飛び上がって大変幸せを感じる
では それから指輪はちょっと手を洗ったり
いろいろお化粧したりしなくちゃあかんだからね
お化粧っていうのは車のペンキ塗る工場ぐらい大変なものだから
いろいろマスキングしなくちゃあかんだからね
とにかくこれ ダイヤをちょっと置いておいて
まあ何かやっている それで何かのわけでダイヤがなくなる
まあ滑っちゃう 何かの穴に入っちゃって
そのまま流されてしまっちゃったと
しまったと まあ下水道に入ってそれ探せませんしね
はい ではもう条件 2つ
ダイヤがもらってすごい嬉しい幸福を感じた
次にダイヤがなくなった
なくなった瞬間で何を感じるのかというと
幸せは感じません それで私のポイントは
あなたにダイヤがもらった時のあの幸福感を
ダイヤがなくなったんだよと
いわゆる指輪がなくなったんだよと言われたって
あ そう でも私幸せよと舞い上がっていることはできますかね
これがポイントなんです
苦労して家を建てる それで
ああ やっと家建てた 新しいマイホームで
まあこれから楽しく生活できるんだと
で 喜びを感じる パーティーもやる
ウォーミングパーティーというんですね
もやります そこで仕事に行ったところで
ちょっとしたことで 電気ショートでも何か起きちゃって
家が全部消えちゃう 火事になっちゃって
で 家が火事になったという話を聞いて
あるいは見て あ せっかく苦労して建てた家が瞬時に消え去った
それでできますかね 家が家を作ってホームウォーミングパーティーもやって
すごい楽しく 新しい家具も買って入った時のあの喜びはそのまま火事になっても家が
まあでも家は火事になったんだから
住むところはないんだけど
私は楽しいんだと 幸福はそのままやと言えますかね
これは無理ですね やっぱり我々の心は物に依存しているんですよ
無理です で 心はそういうことで揺らぐんです
心は揺らぐ ワーリジェをタローワーリ嬢はたれきっと多くもうこと仏パリパンデティタンチッタンマーラデイヤンパハト
これは今日のテーマへ
ちょっと難しくなりますけど
あまり説明に入りません
陸に上げた魚が怯えて飛び跳ねるように
この心も揺らぐのです
魔の支配を捨てるべきですと
魔の支配っていうのは
この物に依存する世界を捨てなさいと
我々の心が陸に 陸に上げた魚のように常に揺らいでいます
パンダナンチャパランチッタンドゥラッカンドゥンニワーリヤン
心は揺らぐ 守り難い 次の偈はカットしました
偈は難しくなるんだからね
で お釈迦様も心のこの揺らぎが問題にしたんですね
これがダンパどの はい
それで我々の生き方はどうなっているのかというと
不幸が幸福を代行する人間なんですね
私たちの人生は 幸福 ちょっと文法間違ってます
幸福を目指して不幸へ進むんです
あの幸福を目指して不幸へ進む
心が無知です 弱いんです
煩悩で汚れています あべこべの判断します
希望と正反対の結果になります
これは面白いんですよ
人間が何か希望すると
結果が反対の結果になる
何かやろうとすると 結果が違う
反対なんですね 平和で生きていようと思っちゃうと
戦争になっちゃうんです
経済的に成長しようとすると
生き苦しくなるんです
健康で健康に徹底的に気をつけましょうと思った後
早く病気になる 早くも病気になって倒れます
なんだこりゃ どうも希望と反対の結果がすっと我々経験しているんです
これは心が弱くて 臆病者で
無知で煩悩に汚れているんだから
判断能力はないわ 計画能力はないわ
実行能力はないわ もうあてにならん
揺らがない 奪われない幸福に達するためには
心の問題 病を解決しなくてはならないのです
では これから幸福の世界を考えましょうよ
幸福になりたければ 金儲けましょうね
そうじゃないでしょ 幸福になりたければ
一番人気のある美人と結婚しましょうよと
そうじゃないんですよ
これすごい勘違いなんです
幸福になりたければ 心の病を治さなくちゃあかんのです
幸福は物にあるんじゃないんです
もう幸福の住所を教えたでしょ
住所を教えたんだから
まっすぐそちらに行けばいいでしょうに
はい これからこの心の病気
いわゆる診断ですね これしないと治療できないんですね
診断してみます 我々の心は病気ということは
心は誰かにいじっているんですよ
例えば皆様がね インフルエンザで倒れましたと言ったら
皆様を管理しているのは誰ですかね
インフルエンザウイルスでしょ
インフルエンザウイルスに負けちゃって
インフルエンザウイルスが言うように倒れちゃいますね
だから病気になると病気が人を管理するでしょ
どうしても 自分の希望通りに生きていられませんよ
例えばすごい高血圧 危険な状態
それ気にしないで食べたいものは食べて
スポーツしたい放題スポーツしてとかね
それはできません ずっと高血圧
その病に自分を管理する
病が自分を管理する 最近なんかすごい文法間違えちゃいます
私はちょっとわからない
まあボケているということ
証拠ですからね 気にしないでください
で 風邪ひいたら風邪が私を管理する
自分やりたいことできないんです
ですから もし人が人の心が病
病気だったら その心の病気が心を管理するんです
それぐらいの話があって
このタイトルをつけたんです
病気 病気と闘うというフレーズありますけど
本当のところは病気が自分を管理してますよ
生き方を 第一は無知です
我々は無知に管理されています
皆様の人生の社長は誰ですか？無知です
無知が社長 自分の我が人生のという会社の社長が無知なんですね
とても危険なことなんです
まだ副社長もいますけどね
社長が無知です 無知というのは
この無常苦無我を認めない
否定するんです 世界中人類は無常は認めないんです
そんなアホなと思っているんです
何言うのかいと まあ世の中を見るといろんな変わるのわかりますけどね
そんな程度のことに そんなもうギャーギャー言う必要あるのかいと
地球は永遠たり 心は 永遠たり
魂は永遠たりでしょうにと
無常という連中はね 絶対全知全能の神の神の存在は知りませんよと
私はこのいろいろテキストを読む場合は
はっきりそういう言葉あったんですよ
ある人はブッダの教えがね
間違っていると言っている場合は
ブッダの教えは間違っているのは難しいんだと
彼の分析がね 見事にその通りだと
まあ相当のけた違い頭のいい人間がそこまで認めるんですよ
しかし 残念ながら ゴータマが全知全能の神の存在は知らなかったと
偉そうなこと あの書いてるやつが神の存在知ってますかね
ローマ教皇さえも知らないくせに
誰も知らないから妄想でしょうに
ですから これなんですよ
世界の人類 皆様も我々みんな無常と言った途端に
いや 嫌でしたよ そんな言葉聞きたくない
ネガティブ的で悲観的で
なんて暗い言葉かいと
もっと明るい単語ないのかいと言うんです
ありますけどね あんたは世界一愚か者やと
だって無常は真理でしょう
それから苦 生きることはいくら頑張っても虚しく終わりますよと
これ認めないんですね
なんて素晴らしい人生にそんなケチつけるのかいと
と腹を立ってくるんです
かかってくるんです それから無我
変わらない実態ありませんと
変わらないものは何もないんだよと
言った途端 へーと思っちゃうんです
あるんじゃないと思っちゃうんです
そういうことで 世の中
生命は誰でも 無常苦無我を否定する
わかってもないくせに
研究もしていないのに
調べようともしていないのに
永遠があると前提的に妄信しているんです
これが無知ということ
社長です 人生の この社長の命令で我々は人生計画を築いて頑張っているんです
ですから 人生は運命に
神様に任せるんです ほとんどの人々は運命ですよとかね
何か都合が悪いところが出てきたら
神様 アメリカの大統領も自分がビシビシ頑張って
アメリカに経済状況ね
アメリカの問題を解決するべきところ
神様助けてくれと言うんですね
一か八かという状態で生きる
この無知の感情があると
結構人々は一か八かという生き方をするんです
あるいは神様に 仏様に
おかえる様に 狐様に いろいろ
もういろんなものに頼る
それから一部の人間がやってみなきゃわからんでしょうと
いきなり飛び込んでやっちゃうんですね
冗談じゃないんですよ
ちゃんとした計画があって
実行する時点になったら
まあやってみなきゃわからないでしょうと
結果というのは構わないよ
我々はどうなるかもわかったことでも
推測 推測したことも もう考えたこともなく
やってみなきゃわからないでしょと言って生きてみるんですよ
それは無知に支配されています
それから理性はない 常に興奮状態
無知に心を管理されると理性はない
いつでも興奮して イライラして
動物園にいる動物みたいですね
落ち着きがない 集中できない
それから簡単に諦める
これは無知の特色なんですね
皆様には全くないだろうと思いますけど
で 無知な人は何か始めても簡単に諦めるし
集中しないんですね はい
これはこの社長のやり方なんですね
人生という会社の社長が鞭さんですね
鞭様はこういうふうな我々の人生を管理します
これは社長の会社運営のポリシーです
ありがたいですね で 2
番目 これは怒りですね
これは副社長ですよ 都合の悪いものは我慢できない状態
自分の人生の副社長も二人がいて
副社長も我々を管理する
一つは怒りですね 怒りっていうのは
都合の悪いものは我慢できなくなっちゃうんです
すごい攻撃的なんですね
嫌なものは壊す気持ちが強い
この世の中でこの戦争があったり
問題あったりする この怒りですよ
相手に攻撃できない場合は
その怒り自分に向けて自滅する
怒りの副社長のやり方っていうのは
とにかく壊し屋で壊して壊していくんですね
何でも壊せるわけないでしょう
相手が大きくて壊せないんですね
その場合は その怒りを自分にあいつは憎し憎い
我慢できないというふうに自分で怒って
自分に怒りを向けて自滅する
だから会社倒産です ということは人生倒産です
終わりです 人間も人を攻撃できる範囲で攻撃します
人を馬鹿にしたいすることできれば馬鹿にする
いじめることはできる範囲でいじめる
しかし 相手が凶暴で馬鹿にしたいしたいんだけどできなくなっちゃうと
悔しくて悔しくて自己破壊をする
どちらでも破壊になります
それから怒りの副社長が後悔
嫉妬 物惜しみと これ妬みでしたっけ？恨み
落ち込みに抑えられている
我々の心はいっぱいですよ
後悔でいっぱい 嫉妬でいっぱい
物惜しみでいっぱい 恨みでいっぱい
もうどうにもならん 幸せ感じる余裕はないんです
これは副社長の仕事なんですよ
副社長の会社経営ポリシーです
幸福を期待するが 何の喜びも感じない
だから我々は幸福を目指して社長を選んで副社長も選んでますよ
でも この社長と副社長と副社長がこんな結果を作ってくれるんです
はい  3番目 もう一つ副社長がいるんです
これは欲ですね 物事に執着する
自分のものにしたいという気持ち
これは結構ありますね
我々には 自分のものにしたい
何でも手に入れようとするんですね
この副社長のポリシーは
とにかく何でも手に入って入れてくださいと
ものや人を束縛するんですね
もう鎖で束縛して鍵かけて置いておくんです
欲しいと思うだけでリミットはありませんね
この副社長の場合はリミットがないんですよ
あの怒りの場合は自滅しますからね
それはリミットです 欲の場合はリミットがないんです
人やら物やらを束縛させて
束縛させて 束縛させて
これで家族にあまりにも束縛
家族を束縛しようとすると
家族も攻撃してテロ行為をして逃げ出するんですよ
欲という副社長が何でも手に入れよう
手に入れたものはぎゅっと握りしめておきましょうということをするんです
いくらあっても満足しないんですね
この副社長は だから幸福にならないでしょ
不満ばっかしですから
善し悪しの判断ができない
欲という副社長には 物事の善し悪し判断できない
可愛いと思ったら毒蛇も買っちゃうような
馬鹿なんです だから我々は欲のせいでいろんなものに手を出して
結構火傷してるでしょ
例えば人々はアル中になったり
賭け事に行ったり 麻薬を使ったりする場合は
もう手を焼いてますね
善し悪し知らない はい
今までの話から言うと
私たちは幸福だと 物が幸福だと勘違いしている
それで依存症という病気が出ている
で それから幸福は物ではなく
心の状態であると説明しましたね
しかし この心が怪しいという説明になりました
すごく揺らぐ それから汚れている
病気 次に私は心の診断書を説明しました
どこら辺病気でしょうかということで
その時冗談でね 人生という会社の社長と副社長がいるんだということで
社員もいるんです 一般的に
大げさに言えば千五百煩悩と言うんだからね
社員はそれぐらいいますけど
社長と副社長と二人 他なくてもそれでわかりますね
はい それがヴィーラスで
心を病気にする原因です
そこがなくなってしまえば
心は安定するんですね
そうすると覚えない幸福ができます
これはおかしいんだけど
例えば なんか何言おうかな
宝くじを 1 等賞当たったと
で 楽しみ 幸福を感じる
この紙が破れてしまっちゃったと
言うと 普通の人だったらどん底落ち込むんですね
宝くじが当たっても幸せで
当たったくじを他の人が持っていったっても同じ幸せでいられる状態
幸せは誰にも奪う奪うことはできません
家があってもなくても同じ幸せで
金があってもなくても幸せいっぱいで
健康であっても病弱であっても幸せいっぱいで
自然災害があってもなくても同じレベルで揺らがない幸せ
築くためには心の治療が必要になるんですね
物の獲得ではなく 心の成長が安らぎの道です
これからびっくりしますからね
方法は 最近私がまあなんかいろんなところで使っているフレーズです
で 私にも流行っていうものあります
今私の流行語は この人生はレンタルです
私の流行語はすごい賢いやと勝手に思ってますけど
誰もそう思ってくれませんね
単細胞で我々は生まれるんです
何も持ってないんです
この単細胞は何かというと
その細胞を作った材料は両親の体から排泄するものなんです
私は学校で科学を学んでないんだけど
嘘じゃないと思います
精子も卵子も体から排泄する排泄物なんです
その言葉は 私はお釈迦様が使っている単語はそのまま日本語にしただけ
あなた方は排泄物で作られているんだよと
だからかっこ悪いんですよ
親と言うんだけど 親の体が排泄する排泄物で
やっと 1個の細胞を作るんですね
生まれる時は 3兆個ぐらいに増えて
60兆個まで成長します
この単細胞が 生まれる赤ちゃんが 30兆ぐらいだというんですね
これ 書き方はおかしいやと思いますけど
で で 大人の細胞の数はね
60兆もいるし  80兆もいるし
100兆ともいうしね
まあいいかげんだと思いますけど
一般的には 60兆というですね
で増えるんですよ だから一個の排泄物がドカーンと 60兆まで増えたんだから
排泄物には変わりはありませんよ
この体は 細胞増えるんだから
元のコピーするための使った元の細胞はすぐなくなりますけど
そこからコピーしてコピーして同じ中身で作っていきますよ
ただ 遺伝子は全く同じコピーでしょう
例えば心臓の細胞と体の細胞がちょっと形が違うんだけど
寿命も違うんだけどね
骨の細胞も形が違うし
寿命も違うんだけど 遺伝子は同じです
同じものをコピーしてコピーしてコピーして作るんです
分化する過程で ちょこちょこっと形違う細胞になるだけで
だから体そのまま排泄物なんです
この体 一切借りたもので
自分のものでも あの世から持ってきたものでもありません
すべて我々は借りたものです
だから お母さんの体の中に依存している時でも
普通は体は自分のために作る血液でしょうに
一部は取っちゃいますね
奪うんです だから子供が生まれたらその血管がなくなるでしょ？胎盤とかなんとか外れますからね
排泄するんです あれ 寄生するんですね
母体に 胎児が寄生するんだから
栄養は全部奪ったもんです
借りたもんです それからジャガイモやらね
ミルクやら米やらね チキンやら
いろんなもう排泄物で体を作ってます
なんで食べるものに私は排泄物かというと
食べるものには命がないんですよ
私たちは牛を食べませんね
牛が死んで死体になって処分する
自然に戻す 戻る状態になったら
その肉を取るんですね
その肉 さらに ゴミにしてから
いわゆる焼いたり いろんなことをしてね
さらにゴミにしてから食べるんです
ジャガイモにも なんとか微妙に命があるんだけど
そのまま食べませんね
殺して死骸を食べてるんです
果物はどうか言って問題ありますけど
果物はどうしても腐るものなんですね
果物は木は排泄するんですね
これ食っちゃえと だから木が必ず落ちるんですね
捨てるんです だから果物はそのまま生で食べられますけど
命がないんです 結局種ぐらいですね
では 種に命がありますけど
皆様 種どうやって食べます？じゃあピーナツは生で食べますかね
殺して食べてます そういうことで
地球の品物は排泄物状態の排泄とその時は言わないんですね
ゴミにしてから体を作ってますよ
一つも自分のものではないんです
あの世からこの世に生まれますけど
何も持ってきてないんです
その上 体を維持するために無数の品物を借りるんです
今 食べ物だけの説明したでしょ
服はどうします？車は？パソコンは？携帯は
炊飯器 冷蔵庫 いろんな品物あるわあるわあるわ
それは体の中には入れませんね
なかなか命が成り立たないんですよ
だから携帯も買うわ テレビも買うわ
炊飯器も冷蔵庫も買って
服も買って 家も買って
車も買ったりと いろんなもの
時々家に何か絵でも買ってきてかけたりします
花も立てたりします 家具も買います
どれぐらいの品物を買うかともよくわからないんですよ
とにかくいろんなものを買ってもらって
皆様の家も私の家も同じですけど
使う品物っていうのはほんのわずかで
使わない品物でいっぱいなんです
そういうことで すべてレンタルであると
借りたものであると 自分のものではないと
体さえも覚えてほしい
で レンタルした体を使う場合は
レンタルの規則があるんですよ
決まりがあるんです この決まりはみんな破っているんです
自分のものだという 権利はありません
レンタルしたものに自分のものだと言ってはあかんでしょ
外国旅行するためにカバンをレンタルする
あ これ私のカバンと言ってはならんよ
その気持ちも作ってはいけません
レンタルだ レンタルだと
思わないと 丁寧に使わなくてはならないんですね
結婚式でウェディングドレスをレンタルしたら
いい加減使ってはあかんよ
丁寧に使わなくちゃあかん
車をレンタル 皆様は大体車をレンタルした経験あるでしょう
これは私の車だよと言わないでしょうに
それから丁寧に使うでしょうに
それから覚えてください
レンタル料を払いなさい
ただじゃないんです 何一つ
無料レンタルはないんです
正しく使わなかったら
その分弁償するんです
それも決まりです 使い方間違ったら
壊したら 勉強しなくちゃいけない
使用後返すんです この規則を覚えてください
笑っちゃうでしょ 笑わないね
誰も だからおそらく自分の人生はすごいと思ってるでしょうね
ただのレンタルですけど
で 時々ね 皆様どこか行ったらホテルに泊まるでしょ？まあビジネスホテルだったら料金はそんな高くないんです
私も自分の国のホテルの料金と比較して
日本の方が安いんじゃないかなと
ビジネスホテルですけど
で まあでも国のホテルはね
スケールが結構違うし
食べ物のレベルも違いますけど
まあビジネスホテルで小さな部屋をね
ベッド入れたらもうぎゅうぎゅう何も入れません
自分のカバンも置く場所がない程度
しかし レンタル料金は安いんだけど
もし何か壊したら あの
お風呂の鏡でも壊したらどうなるんですかね
すごいお金払う羽目になります
はい 次 支払い方法 あの
この場合はクレジットカードは通じません
クレジットカードも私もよく使いますけど
Paypal という あのネットで品物を買うとき支払い方法がありましてね
そういうのはではないんです
よく覚えてください 生きている間は皆と仲良くしなくちゃいかんですよ
あれ 嫌でしょ 本当は でも嫌であっても仲良くしなくちゃいけないんです
それが料金です それで払いますよ
勉強しなくちゃあかんでしょ
本当は嫌でしょ 生まれたからには勉強しなくちゃいけない
技術を学ばなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで生きているこの体に対するレンタルを払っているんです
仕事をしなくちゃいかんでしょ
それもレンタルです 支払い方法です
仕事をすることは支払いです
学ぶことは支払いです
みんなと仲良くすることは正しく料金を払っています
レンタル料を払っています
それから社会の決まりを守らなくちゃいけないんですね
社会と国が 2つですけどね
国の決まり 法律も社会の決まりも
社会の場合 法律はないんだけど
守らなくちゃいけない
守らなかったらひどい目に遭います
文句を言わず 自分の義務を果たすんです
やりたくない やりたくないってよく言うこと
我々は 借りたら体をね
いろいろ義務が生じているんです
ちゃんと文句言わないで果たすんです
例えば親孝行する 家族サービスするなどなどです
もうたくさんありますよ
義務というもの 例えば
日本社会においては中間
お正月のあれはなんて言いますか
え？正保お歳暮やらお中元やら
もうしなくちゃいけない
面倒くさいやとかね そんなワンパターンの品物をもらったっても
もらった人にもダメ 本当はゴミなんですけどね
幸い私はもらわないんです
欲しいという意味じゃないんです
もらったらどうせゴミだと思いますけどね
で それでもどうしようもないんですよ
お歳暮を贈るべき人には贈らなくちゃいけない
年賀状を出すべき人にも出さなくちゃいけない
中元を贈る人には贈らなくちゃいけない
要するに 生まれたからには苦労して生きなくてはならないんです
やることあるわ あるわ
あるわ 時々忘れちゃうでしょうね
忘れるぐらい我々にはやるべきこといっぱいあるんです
忘れたらあかんよ 大変なことになります
あのお墓参りは忘れちゃってもいいんだけど
その時インチキ詐欺師たちが来てね
あなたは不幸になっているのはお墓参りしていないんだからよ
ご先祖様が怒ってあなたに罰が当たって
そういうのはありませんだからね
で 親孝行することですよ
大事なのは だからそういうことで日本文化が攻撃してくるんですよ
お墓参りしなかった 参りしなかったんだと
逃げる道はありません
これが生き方なんですね
仕事をしないで逃げることはできません
結婚しても奥さんが私はあの
何病というんですか？主婦業はやりたくないとかね
結婚した男は私は夫としての義務を果たしたくないとかね
これでは生きていられませんよ
子供は私は勝手に生まれたんだからね
あなた二人の話は聞きたくないと
成り立ちませんよ だから文句を言わず
義務を果たす人がレンタル料金をちゃんと納めているんです
人生の 人生はレンタルだから
はい なんでこの変なことを私は言うのかというと
これであの社長をクビにするんです
ムチッという で それから人生のレンタルした人生の乱れた使い方とは
わがままで生きる 目の上の人のしつけアドバイスに耳を傾けない
暴飲暴食その他違法的な行為をする
これはレンタルしたものはそんなことしてはあかんでしょうに
欲に溺れて生きること
体が早く壊れるので 病弱になり
弁償する羽目になる 例えば欲に溺れるとがんになったり
あらゆる病気になるでしょう
すごいお金かかるでしょう
で 放射線治療とかね 抗がん剤とか受ける羽目になったら考えてください
どれほど苦しいかと なんで普通に生きていられないんですかね？どこかで使い方乱れたんですね
これは弁償なんですよ
食べるものに気をつけないで
ないでパクパク食べちゃって
心筋梗塞とかできちゃうと
弁償は並みじゃないんですよ
え 欲張ってむさぼって物を収集する
人々見いますよ なんかゴミ屋敷作る人々いますけど
あれ収集屋なんですね
それでお金がないんだからゴミを持ってくるんです
ひどい目に遭うでしょ
私たちはあれやこれやとかね
収集するんですよ それで考えてください
たくさん財産を財産を収集したら
弁償する羽目になるんです
だって遺言書を書かなくちゃいけないし
誰に誰にどうしようかとかね
子供はこれからお互い憎しみ合って殺し合いやるだろうとかね
いろんなトラブルが起こるんですよ
穏やかで生きていられなくなります
自然 他の生命を大事にしない
それで私たちは自然を大事にしないでしょう
自然を守らないんですね
破壊する 弁償するんですよ
必ず 例えば今 水を買って飲んでいるでしょう
日本では買う必要はないと思いますけど
私も買うことにしています
東京の水道の水はちょっともしかすると放射能に汚染しているかもしれませんと
で 自然破壊したことで人間がすごい弁償になっているんです
面白いことは この エコ税って税金まで取っているんですね
我々からお金を奪っちゃえば
自然は元に戻るんですかね
だから二酸化炭素削減しようと思ったら
では税金をあと 2%上げるぞと
それだけ その世界もその方々もおかしいんですね
だから他の生命には不親切
人間だけじゃないんですよ
すべて動植物に我々不親切で生きていますよ
全部弁償する羽目になります
今のリストは 我々はレンタルした品物を乱れた使い方をします
の例なんです 誰一人も規則を守っていないんです
誰も人生はレンタルだと思っていないんです
権利があると思っているんです
何の権利もないんです
料金払いなさいと 私には生きる権利があるんだぞと言っているでしょう
ないんです 本当は ちゃんとレンタル料を払っているならば生きていられます
レンタルを払わなかったら
それで取り戻されます
体 命はなくなります はい
次 奪われない幸福の気づき方
なんか見えなくなっちゃったね
これで見えます で これは本当にびっくりという感じで聞いた方が
心に残るんです このレンタル論なんかは
なんだつまらないではなくて
なんだ何？びっくりという気持ちで聞いてほしいんです
突飛な考え方だと しかし事実ですけどね
奪われない幸福の築き方のセカンドステージ
夜なしする前に自己の心を育てるんです
よくも夜なしに人々は行くんだからね
じゃあみんなで自然を守りましょうよとかね
何言って言い張るんですかね
では世界平和を では正義の味方をとかね
やっていること全部違反なんですよ
正義の味方になり上がる前に
自分が何者かと で 世間に広がっている正義の味方っていうのは
強者 強者と言うんですか
それから乱暴な人の生き方なんですよ
だって正直なところを言うと
アメリカが考えること
アメリカの価値観 すべて正義なんですね
我々には押し付ける アメリカが世界一強いんだから
もう地球破壊するぐらいの軍事力を持っているんだから
ただそれだけの話でしょう
軍隊は必要ですけど 自分の国を守るために
ですから 正しいのは己の心を直すんです
で 心はレンタルではないんです
肉体は全部排泄物で作ったものです
ゴミで作ったものです
心はそうじゃないんです
だからまたレンタルに入りますけど
免許証を持っている人は車をレンタルするでしょ
レンタル業者には関係ありません
レンタル業者は車にはいちいち言うんだけど
自分の免許証については何とも言う権利がないんです
我々は車は返しますけど
免許証は返しません 例えばレンタル業者が車を返してもらうときは
はい あなたの君の免許証も返してくださいと
できませんね そのように肉体はレンタルですけど
心は世間には関係ないんです
この世で生 生まれを司るエネルギーは心です
だから あの両親が排泄した細胞を自然法則で一緒になりますけど
そこで組み合わせて命になるんですよ
遺伝子が組み合わさっちゃって
ここに心とエネルギーが働くんです
だから 同じ両親に生まれる子供もそれぞれ違うんですよ
一人が女になるし 一人は男になるというとかね
それから一人がすごい頭のいい人間になるし
一人がすごい体格の良い人間になるし
いろいろ またある一人が体格はあまり良くない
部品が故障している 故障ではなくて欠けている
そういう風にも出てくるんです
だから心はエネルギーを持ってるんですね
心は自分を持っているエネルギーに合わせて
ぎっしりと排泄物の細胞をつなげるんです
人類の遺伝子はだいたい同じでしょう
そんな差がないんです
しかし 人類は一人一人違いますね
天才もいて とんでもない無知な人もいるでしょう
いろんな それは心のエネルギーなんですね
幸福 幸福を期待するのは心であって体ではないんです
心が体を作ったんですよ
作ったんではなくてレンタルしたんです
だから心がこのレンタルした品物を思い存分使いたいんですよ
乱れた生き方をして不幸になるのは
心が汚れによって乱れているからです
そこでレンタルはしたんだけど
車はレンタルしたんだけど
こいつは酔っ払い これで大変なことになるでしょ
免許はありますよ あるいは若者たちはしっかりと車を運転
車は借りたんだけど なんかふざけて遊びながら
お互い蹴ったり踏んだりしながら歌いながら運転して事故っちゃうと
その場合も明らかに心が乱れているんですね
それでレンタルした品物の使い方乱れたんですね
ということで 我々の一切の失敗の原因は心にある
一切の幸福の不幸の原因は心にある
頭がいいか悪いかは心次第です
体力があるかないかも心次第です
生まれつき弱い体で生まれたら心は弱いんです
それで心の改革改良プログラムがあります
で そこでちょっと早く終わるので
あの業ということに触れます
あの心は変化して変化して心も無常ですよ
瞬間で心変わるんです
あまりにも早いんだから
無常はね なんかあるのごとく見えるんですね
例えば今 このスクリーンに映す光も
本当は 生まれては消えているんですよ
あまり早いんだから スーッと光あるのごとく錯覚するんです
そしてこのパソコンも
いつでも同じものを出していたって
そうじゃないんで 中でずっと新しい新しい画面作ってますよ
なんとかレートとありましてね
モニターを調整するんですよ
リフレッシングレートというんですけどね
で かなり早く かなり早く新しい新しい画面を作るんで
今もこれは画面どれぐらい変化したかわからないんですよ
あまりにも早いんだから
よくわからない 私は今 22枚目のスライドですけど
23にすると皆様わかりますね
あ スライドが変わりましたと
それは遅いんだからなんです
それで心がすっごく早く変化するんだから
スーッと一貫して我が心あるという勘違いするんです
本当は心は無常です しかし
心にはすごいエネルギーがあるんです
それは業というんです
エネルギーがないと動けないんだから動けませんだからね
だからもう勉強して 満点取りたいと
気持ちはあるんだけど
心のエネルギーによって点数が決められちゃいます
会社に入って社長になりたいという気持ちはあっても
自分の心のエネルギーに合わせてどこまで上がるのかということは決まるんです
だから会社に入って社員で人生終わる人もいるし
で 課長で終わる人もいるし
係長もっと下なんですね
まあそうやって部長で終わる人もいるし
社長代理で終わる人もいるし
社長になってしまう人もいるし
そういうことで この業というものはずっと働いています
それから目があるでしょ
目にはどこまで見えるかという階数券みたいな能力は決まっているんですね
増えません それも業なんです
目はもう使って使って回数券終わると目が見えなくなるんです
耳はどれぐらい音を認識するかという量が決まってあって
それが終わっちゃうと聞こえない
だから音楽家の方々は結構耳が病気になるでしょ
聞こえなくなったりもする
乱視と同じく難聴になったりもする
だからすごい苦労しますよ
自分が難聴なのに歌わなくちゃいけない
大変です だから回数券終わってるんですね
一生食べると言ったってもね
食べる量が決まってます
だから気をつけないと
例えばたくさん食べられる人もいるでしょ
それほど食べてないんだけど
あまり食べられない人もいる
これは各自で判断して
丁寧にレンタルしたものを使わなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 一生食べるべき糖分
砂糖を形で食べ終わったらどうなるんですかね
もう砂糖は受け入れられなくなります
体が それで病気になって
目が見えなくなって もう部品が足とかね
もうなんか壊死して腐ってしまって死にます
だからこの心のエネルギーで正しく使っていない乱れた使い方したんですね
だから寿命が縮んだんです
例えば 家を借りるときは 2 年間で契約する
しかし  1ヶ月以内で使い方間違っちゃうと追い出されますね
まだ契約残ってるでしょ？って言ったってもダメです
契約書の決まりはちゃんと守らなくちゃいけないんです
そのように この世で排泄物で命を借りたんだけど
契約はあるんです その契約も業ということなんです
仏教では はい それで心を直すプログラムとして
まず言えるのは 道徳を守ってくださいと
道徳を守ると全部しっかり管理するんです
正しく この道徳っていうのは大げさなものではないんです
断食をするとか 菜食などではなく
世界的に認められている正しい生き方ですよ
食べる時も食べ過ぎではないとかね
飲む時でも飲む過ぎにならないとか
嘘をつかないとか 人を騙さないとか
生命は殺さないとか 他人のものは奪わない
自分で料金を払って もらう
あの万引きをするんじゃなくて
仕事をして金を持ってお金を払って品物を買う
万引きは盗みでしょ だからこの大それたことではないんですよ
大胆なことじゃないんで
道徳っていうのは 道徳とは
返答した体を正しく使うこと
規則を守って使うことなんです
だから道徳は守りたくない
道徳は面白くないとかね
学校では道徳でしたっけ？あるのは
で これもう子供たちもあまり勉強したくないし
先生たちも道徳を教えて何を教えればいいかわからないんですね
まあくちゃめちゃめちゃなことを言うんです
ある日 NHKで道徳番組道徳授業についてプログラムが作ってあったんですね
でもすごい金かかってる
すごい金かかって プログラム作って
道徳を犯すことは道徳であるとか結論に達するんですね
そんなものじゃないんですよ
道徳から逃げられませんし
守るべきでしょうし これは契約書ですよ
それから欲 怒り 嫉妬 わがままなどの感情に負けて話したり
行動したりしないこと
例えば車レンタルしたら酒飲んではいけません
歌うのはいいんだけど
運転手もみんなと一緒に手を振って歌ったりして
それダメです だってみんな楽しく歌ってるんだからね
気分が良くなるでしょ
自分も好きな歌ですね
そこで自分も足を踏んだり
手をやったりすると 運転手がどうなるんですか
いくら自分の好きな歌が流れていたっても
冷静にハンドルを握って足をちゃんとコントロールして運転しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから人生の場合も 欲が出てきたら気をつけて喋らないことにする
行動しないことにする
欲が起きて行動しちゃうと
痴漢するわ あるいは不倫するわ
万引きするわ 強盗する
わからないことをやっちゃいますよ
怒り 嫉妬があって行動すると何するかわからないでしょ
わがままで行動したら
生意気で後で大変なことになりますね
ですから この感情が来る
生意気の気分にもなる
怒りもこみ上げてくる
その時は停止するんです
言葉も動きも停止して
じーっとレンタルしたそのものを守ってあげるんです
規則を破らないで 次 一切の生命に対して慈しみを実践する
これが私の言葉が間違っているかどうか分かりませんだけど
私はこれはお釈迦様しか教えていないと思いますね
愛っていう言葉あるんだけど
あれは愛着の愛なんですね
あれは良くないんです
なんで愛するんですかね
慈しみですよ ものすごく違います
ものすごく違います 宗教家たちが言っている愛であってもダメです
あれは あのイエスの言葉を調べたら
愛とは自分を愛することであって
神を愛することだと 自分と神
とんでもない言葉と思ったんですよ
それから  その愛の表現として
他の隣人も同然と だから神どうやって愛するんですかね
仏教は慈しみというものを教えているんですね
慈しみっていうのは 誰を見てもみんなレンタルした体を持って苦労しながらレンタル料金を払っている
で 面白いことは 我々人間が他の人間の助けがなければ生きていられないんですね
他の人々の助けも借りなくちゃいけないんです
人が助けてあげるべきという義務はないんです
我々は助けてもらっているんです
助けを借りているんです
だから 生まれた瞬間から助けてもらっているんです
物質は借りるんだけど
排泄物を借りますけど
やっぱり親の優しい気持ちがなければ育たないでしょう
だから親の愛情というものは借りているんです
あれは借りているんです
借りたものにはそれなりのお返しが必要です
人は金だけでは生きていられませんし
人はご飯だけでは生きていられませんという言葉もありますけど
有名な あの それは覚えているでしょ
どこにあったっけ あの言葉は
人はパンだけでは生きていられませんと
仏教は知らないんだけど
それは知ってるでしょ
聖書にあるんですね で
我々は冷蔵庫があるとか
車があるとかね 家があるとかね
元気で生きていられますよ
じゃないんですよ 人間の助けが必要なの
そこで互いに助け合って生きているんですよ
だからそこを認めることのおかげさまで
生きてるんだと 神じゃないんです
我々には小さい時ご飯をくれたのは両親なんです
たまにおばあちゃんもご飯くれたんだけど
両親なんです そこを感じることが慈しみなんです
すごい具体的なんです
ご飯食べる時は ちっちゃな子供たちに教えてあげれば
お母さん お父さん ありがとうございますと言うように教えてあげてください
どれほど幸せになるのかと
どれほど心の苦しみがなくなって幸せ感じるのかと
旦那さんが奥さんにありがとうございますと
一言葉言ったら これは毎日のように言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
どれほど幸せかと 奥さんも旦那さんにありがとうございますと
ご苦労様ですと 感謝しています
と いうと その男はどれほど元気に仕事をするのかと
不倫はしませんよ そのように目の前で幸福を感じる
アクションは慈しみを実践することです
で 今日データ調べるとき見つかったことなんですけど
人間の体が億兆の細胞なんですけど
なんか腸の中にはるかにもっとたくさん細菌がいるんだと
数もあったんですけど
忘れちゃった  100兆ぐらいかもっとかな
あれも生き物ですよ 見てください
この 60 兆の細胞を支えるために
腸の中に まあたとえ まあ仮にでも 100 兆ぐらいの他の生命が頑張っているんです
最近 ある医者に聞いた話ですけど
なんか腸の中にあるこのなんとかなんとかの菌が何か何か物質を作るみたいですね
それが血液中 脳に行ったら脳が回転するんだと
だから この 食物繊維をいっぱい入っているものを食べると
あの 何て言ったっけ？病気がうつ病にはかからないんだと
うつ病っていうのは脳が機能低下することだから
この脳のこの電気信号を行くために必要な化学物質は腸で作っているんですね
これで肉ばっかし食ってるんだから
野菜は置いておく たまに見たことあるんですね
もうビーフとかなんとかとかね
焼いて このちょっともうサラダ葉っぱ 1 枚とかね
トマト 1 枚とかね もう人参ちょっと茹でた人参ちょこっと2 3枚とかの丸く輪切りにして置いてあるでしょ
あれは全部残すでしょ
みんな で あの 昔からも私はみんなに笑われたんですけど
サンドイッチ買うと パセリ葉っぱ 1 枚ぐらい入れてあるんですね
時々 2 枚ともありますけど
私は先にそれ食べるんです
みんななんか変な顔して見るんですね
野菜たるもの 私は 1つも残しません
他残しても まあそれは私の個人的な勝手なことで
あの そうやっていう生き方すると
このやっぱり細菌には生きていられなくなっちゃって
で 脳に化学物質なくなるんですね
その時もレンタル理論を覚えてください
細菌たちは自分で生きているんですよ
そこで自分が脳の中の食物繊維とか食べてるんですよ
それで排泄するんです
あの排泄するものは我々の体を受け取っているんです
ビタミンもそうでしょう
腸の中でビタミン作るでしょ
あれ全部排泄物なんです
腸内細菌の だから私のレンタルレンタル理論はしっかり成り立ちます
たとえ腸内にある細菌でも
みんなあの今 あの麹とかね
塩麹健康にとかあれこれってなんか大騒ぎしているでしょ
あれってなんですかね
全部死骸の塊でしょ だから体は排泄物で成り立っているんです
それで言いたかったというのは
60 兆の細胞を支えるために
100 兆ぐらいの細菌が頑張っていなきゃ
健康でいなきゃ 皮膚はすごい
あの外敵から体を守ってくれるでしょ
でも皮膚にこの能力はどうやって入るんですかね
やっぱり細菌ですよ あまりにも 1 日何回も体を洗うとどうですかね
皮膚の状態は荒れますよ
病気になるんです だから皮膚は外の空気に空間に開けておいたっても
細菌たちがちゃんと頑張って守っているんですね
そういうことで レンタルしたこの肉体は
すべての生命の協力があって成り立っているんです
だから慈しみを実践するんです
慈しみを実践すると 乱れた生き方できなくなるんです
みんな協力してくれるんです
賞味期限ちょっと切れたっても
食べ物は当たりませんよ
それで2倍楽しくなるんですね
いつでも楽しい心が幸せを感じる
慈悲の瞑想をすると 慈悲の実践をすると
人を見ても嫌なやつやと思えなくなっちゃうんですね
嫌なやつと思う前に この人も大変でしょうにと
私と同じでしょうにと
野良犬を見て ボロボロで汚くて
もうもう髪の体の毛もなくて
皮膚病であー気持ち悪いんだ
あっちかちけと言えなくなっちゃうんです
あ このワンちゃんが大変だなと
なんて苦労して生きているんでしょうかと
それでも自分なりに頑張っているんでしょうという気持ちが生まれてくるんですよ
その気持ちが幸せなんですよ
あれも嫌 これも嫌という気持ちよりは
だから人生は無常ですけど
ろくなものはないんだけど
そこら辺でポジティブ的に物事を見ることできますよ
私は電車に乗ると いつでも運転者の腕に大したもんだなと思っちゃいますよ
だってしっかりとあの止まる位置に止めるでしょ
あれ 相当難しいだと思います
ある日 新幹線に乗って
ただやることないんだからつまらないんだから
まあゲームでもやろうかと思って
どんなゲームかというと
その日はちゃんと新幹線が動いてたし
東京駅に到着する時間決まってあるんですよ
時は忘れちゃったんですけど
23 分ですね それで私は時計を持ってじーっと見ているんですね
言ったら 見事に東京駅に入ってまだ動いてるんですね
で 時間が合ってないんですよ
秒なんですけど そこで止めて
スーッと音を出してドアを開けると
見たらちょうど 23時23分00
だからそこをいうふうにチェックしたら
どれほど人間が真剣に自分の技術を振る舞っているのかと
楽しいんじゃない？私には楽しいんです
そこで朝晩の満員電車で
あれすごい重いんだから
あのモーターにはね 大変ですよ
それでも運転手がちゃんと時間に持っていくんですよ
車を だから私は感じるんですね
かなりパワー入れてるんだとか
足裏で感じるんですよ
モーターたちがプンって回転してるんですね
その時わかるでしょ そういうのは開発した人々の能力
それから運転する人のあのハンドルの使い方
で それで困るのは 坂が出てくると上るじゃなくて下りるところにあれほどパワーでいったらかなり大変なことになるでしょ
ないんですよ しっとコントロールして
上り坂も下り坂も持っていく
私はもうそういうことを調べて
なんとなく世の中の人間についてすごいポジティブ的な気持ちになるんですね
ありがたいなと 例えばね
インドでもものすごい電車事故が起こるでしょ
ヨーロッパでも何回起きたしね
日本では日本の新幹線は一回も
これって考えればものすごくすごいことでしょうに
だから見てください 私はただ新幹線に乗って
自分の忙しくてもうイライラして降りるだけの話なんですけど
なんかどこかでなんか喜びを感じている
感謝の気持ちを感じている
ありがたいという気持ちを感じている
幸せってそんなもんなんですよ
だから それにはこの慈しみを実践しなくちゃいけないんですよ
慈しみを実践すると 花がかっこよく完璧になって美しく咲く時は楽しいんです
なんか花びらがぐにゃっとなって
もうほとんど完璧ではなくて
何か障害を持っていて
それでも咲いてくると何か楽しいんですね
頑張ってるんだと 虫に食われちゃって
あるいは栄養に問題があって
あるいは成長する時 何か邪魔が入って
この花はきれいになってないんですが
頑張ってるんだと で だから私にとってはすごく美しく
丸く咲いた花も喜びを与えてくれるし
もうちょっとちっぽけな花でも喜びを与えてくれる
散歩に田舎の方で散歩に行く時は
別に何もなくてもすごい楽しいんですよ
ただ あちらこちら両側で
雑草の中でちょびちょびっと
本当に格好悪い どうったことのない花でなんですけど
咲いていると何か不思議な気分になるんですね
それで安らぎの気分になるんです
そこで環境はすごく悪いところで
でも植物はボロボロですけど
それでも生きているんですね
なんか感謝したくなるんですよ
君は大変ですねとかね
それでもよく頑張ってますよと
と言いたい気分になるんです
NHK の番組を見るとね
ものすごい高い山なんかに登って
すごい険しい環境で もう溶岩の石なんですけど
そこでもある特定の植物たちが現れてきて
花まで咲く 感動しない
だから慈しみさえあれば
喜びを感じさせないものっていうのは
何一つもこの世でないんです
で 私はみんなに馬鹿にされるんだから
あまり言わないんだけど
ちいちゃな男の子たちがあれを見ても
なんかすごい感動して座り込んで見ているでしょ
私はまるっきり同じなんです
蟻一匹見るとじーっと座り込んで見ているんです
感動するんです どこに行くのかい？とかね
どんな目的で行くのかい？とかね
そういうことで 心の改革プログラムとして慈しみを実践するんです
慈しみはものすごいパワフルな実践で
その瞬間から幸福を与えてくれるんです
悩み苦しみを落としてくれるんです
悩む理由がなくなっちゃうんです
これは最強力なんです
共存することは生命の基本法則です
体の細胞は６０ですが
それよりたくさん細胞が腸の中にいるのです
支えられてやっと生きているのだと理解して
一切の差別を捨てて慈しむのです
どこかで支えられています
害虫なんかは存在しないんですよ
最近人気あった本がありまして
南野さんという医者が書いた本でね
そちらにあったある言葉が気に入っていったんですね
細菌 ウイルスなんかはないんだと
それは他の細胞に 他の細胞の遺伝を借りなきゃ生きていられないだけだから
母体壊しちゃうと大元もなくなっちゃいますよと
だから母体を壊せませんと
で 問題は我々の体だと
体がそれは敵扱いしているんだから
病気になるんであって
で 抗体を作って攻撃するんだと
攻撃するときは無差別に
体の細胞も外から来たものも全部片っ端から攻撃するんだよと
それで体が壊れるんであって
病気になるんであって
ウイルスのせいではありませんと
ウイルスが入って体が攻撃しなかったら
ただキャリアになるだけやと
発病はしませんと 発病っていうのは体がするんだそうです
私はそれ そのセクションを読んで
かなり物事を考える人だなと思ったんです
結構ベストセラーになっている本ですけどね
だから 細菌であってもウイルスであっても敵じゃないんです
また あの本にあったのは
この蚊が刺したら痒くなりますね
あれ 蚊の唾液が体に入るんだから痒くなるんだと
で この先生曰く それは間違いますと
蚊が刺してそれから唾液を入れる
それで痒くなったら蚊がパチッとやられますよと
それで蚊の蚊は生きていられなくなっちゃいますよと
だから蚊は入れる唾液では痒くなりませんと
しかし 体がそれが異物として認識して
あの痒みとあの恐ろしい結果が作るんだと
私は蚊に刺されちゃうと
もうもう何時間も苦労するんです
夜は１匹刺したら朝まで眠れないんです
だから考えたら可能性じゃないんで
私も蚊に対してすごく怒っていたんですけど
見たら私の体のせいなんですね
それで思い出したんですよ
ヒルという生命体は蚊よりは大量に血を吸うんです
ものすごい吸うんです
しかし 痛くも痒くもないんです
ヒルがどこか噛んじゃって分からないんです
異物にすごい反応する私の体もヒルに噛まれたことあるんですよ
でも服がなんか濡れてると分かったら血だらけで
それでヒルにやられたと分かるんです
ということは ヒルも血液は固まらない物質を入れるんで
体に でも体がそれよく分からないんですね
敵だと判断しないんです
だからいっぱい吸えます
で ヒルに噛まれて人間が何の病気にもならないんです
ただ血をちょっと頂くだけでしょ
あげたってもいいんじゃないですか
別に 人殺して流す血の量から考えると
それであの あのアイツら入れる唾液で血がドロドロドロドロと出るでしょ
治療はいたって簡単 何もいらん
ただ新聞紙あるでしょ
新聞紙をちょっと一つ切ってパチッと貼っちゃえば終わり
傷跡も何もなくなくなるんです
ということで あ なるほど
この先生言ってることは理屈はあるなと思ったんです
だから我々は一切の差別を捨てて
生命を慈しまなくてはいけない
ある日 どこか覚えてないんだけど
水族館があるところに行ったんですね
その日は私がすごい運がいいやつですよ
私に遭った方がいいんです
その日で水族館が改装工事をやっているんです
ほとんどのもう一番見たいところはセクションは閉鎖してあったんですけど
それでもお金取られちゃったしね
いくらかは見られたんですね
それであるガラスの水槽の中に
何もないんですね 見たら
でも看板ちゃんとありますね
なんとかカメがいるんだと
そのカメ よく見るといるんです
ただ見られるようにディスプレイしているんだから
で このこいつは全くも動かない
しかし 口を開けて 口から何か糸みたいなものが出てきて
赤い ほんのちょっとの
あのとえとえと 何でしたっけ？ミミズではなくて
ちっちゃな虫というかね
ワームですね 英語で言えば小さなワームみたいなものがあって
これが水と一緒に揺らいでいます
それだけあの糸もあまり見えません
こんな感じで口を開けて
あれは魚を騙すためなんですね
魚がこちら石があって
石の上にちょっとした獲物があるんだと思ってそこに行くでしょ
だから獲物を取るために
この頑張ること 皆様に 3 分体動かさないでいられる
感動しないんですかね
あのカメさんの だから体にコケやらね
いろんなものできてるんですよ
だから植物はこれ石だと思ってるんです
動かないんだから 次のところはテレビで見たんですけど
魚がそばにちょこっと行った途端
目に見えないな あの速さは
パクッと食べてるんです
あれくらい速さがあるのに
そこでテレビでは見えなかったでしょうと
あなた方には と ではスローモーションで
動かして見せたんですね
そこで見えたんです 食べられたと
あれぐらい速さを持ってるのに
もう 1週間でも黙って待ってるんです
私にとってはもう感動します
楽しいんですよ 可愛くなるんです
サメが怖いと言うんだけど
サメの体にね いっぱい魚がね
きしむ連中が過ぎてるでしょ
コバンザメって言うと
どんだけ安らげるでしょう
コバンザメってようよう怠け者なんですね
他の魚の体に何か吸盤があって
そこでパチッと体をつけちゃって
まあ楽々なこと 人の体に乗り上がっちゃって
そこで餌をもらったり
するんですね だからそういう風にみんな一生懸命頑張ってるんだと
みんなローンと保険払ってますよ
あれで 自分で自由に動けないっていうこともかなり大変でしょ
コバンザメにしたら だからそういう風に生命を見てほしい
新しい見方で 見ると そこに目の前に限りのない喜び
限りのない安らぎあるんじゃないんですかね
何に困るんですかね 誰に怒るんですかね
誰を嫉妬するんですかね
アホじゃないんですかね
自分勝手で勝手に苦しんでるだけでしょ
自分よりは能力ある人を見つけたら
なんで嫉妬するんですかね
感動すればいいんじゃないんですかね
自分より美しい人を見たら
ああ 美しくて感動しましたよと
この人は過去生で頑張ったんだよと
嫉妬しない人 それから道徳を守る人
生命は優しいと思う人は輪廻転生するとはちゃめちゃ美しい体で生まれるんです
自分が頑張った分がみんなに愛されるんです
今世はどうかわかりませんだけど
テレビでも見るでしょ？子供のタレントさんというかね
もうコマーシャルなんかに出て
あれものすごく可愛いと思いますよ
トイレのおしっこ回しが出る人ともう一人
すごく可愛いやんちゃ的な男の子がいるんです
小さくて 私はすごく楽しいんですね
あのコマーシャルを見ると
逆に結構金儲かってるでしょうね
まだ子供でしょ？なんでやと
やっぱり過去生で頑張ったんです
だからこれ嫉妬 とするんじゃないんです
喜べばいいんです あーかわいいと
はい そういうことで 宗教で教えている愛ではなくて
しっかりした理論的な理性に基づいた
智慧に基づいた慈しみを実践するんです
たちまち幸福を感じるようになります
それで改革プログラムのこれ 2番目かな
またあります 集中力を育てる
何をしてもそれに集中して真面目に行うようにする
皆様方言うでしょ ストレスが溜まっちゃった
もう毎日あれやらなくちゃ
これやらなくちゃ 文句ばっかり言うでしょ
文句を権利ないのに 義務を果たしているだけでしょうに
レンタルを払っているだけでしょうに
しかし いい加減掃除機をかけるとそういう風になるんです
では 集中して掃除機をかけたらどうですかね
集中力がついてくると
心は常に楽しみ 明るさ
喜び 充実感を感じるんです
たとえゴミの分別する時でも
集中してやると相当楽しいんです
で 私が住んでいるところでゴミを入れる場所があって
瓶とか缶とかバラバラなんですけど
みんな瓶をそのまま箱に入れて逃げるんですね
蓋をつけたまんまで 私はそうしません
瓶の蓋を開けて ゆっくりとあれは缶の方に入れて
時々蓋取ったら首がありますね
首も破って入れるんです
ガラスはガラスだけにする
そこで段ボール箱とかはね
別に資源ゴミで捨てますけど
段ボール資源ゴミにする場合はちょっと困ったもんで
テープ貼ってますね 私はむちゃくちゃ苦労してテープを外して
綺麗にそのまま再生できるようにしてゴミに捨てるんです
で やることは手抜きはしません
だから皆様すごいひどい目に遭っているでしょ
講演にしたっても手抜きはないんです
全部言い尽くすんです
で それは集中力というんですよ
で 集中力があると面白いんですよ
私はあんまりインターネット巡りは好きじゃないんだけど
仕事をすることになったらすごく集中して
なんか面白いんだから
各タイトルに合う画像を探しましょうと
探して入れたんです というと
ユーモアもちょっと入れて
また幸福の話ですから
誰でも幸福を感じる いくらなんでも脱走をしなくちゃということに
まあ赤ん坊の赤ちゃんたちの写真にしたんです
ですから 毎日集中してください
何でもいいんですよ もう歯を磨くときはなんで集中しないんですかね
だから歯医者さんにお金を払っているでしょ
あれ 弁償ですね 私は集中して歯を磨くんですよ
しっかりと前と後ろ 上
ちゃんと歯を 4等分に分けて
歯の上も磨くんです で
これは均等にやるのは面倒くさいんだから
電動歯ブラシでいいんです
あれでちゃんと 30 秒じゃなくて
ある時間になったらカチッと音を出してまた動くんです
それでワンセクション終わったら次のセクションに行けば時間も均等なんです
だから考えてください
ただ 歯を磨いても楽しくなるのに
顔を洗う時も楽しくなるのに
なんで皆様方それ忘れてるんですかね
それは探す必要ないでしょう
外で 靴を脱ぐ時でも楽しくなるのに
そういうわけで 集中力はすごい大事なことです
悩み 苦しみ 落ち込みなども減るんです
そこで脳の病気が全部治りますよ
うつ病なんかは治りますよ
自分の心と体の感覚を観察する
これは難しい これは悟りに達するプログラムですね
完全に揺らがない幸福を目指すプログラムです
これはヴィパッサナー実践というんです
今日はやりません あ 時間飛んじゃった
その都度その都度心に起こる汚れがなくす訓練なんです
心には汚れが生まれるんですよ
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 花見たら汚れた
音楽を聴いたら心は汚れた
ですから 自分の体と感覚に気をつけてみるんです
やがて真理を発見して
一切の執着を捨てるのです
一切の苦しみを乗り越えた究極の幸福に達するのです
はい これで完全に誰にも奪われない安らぎを
幸福を身につける方終了しました
2番目は最後に教えたものは大きいプログラムだから今日は省略しています
我々は日常生活はどうすればいいかと
何があっても起きても自然法則だと思う
災害が起きても 何が起きても
それは自然法則だと 子供が自分と喧嘩して家出するぞって出て行ったら
それは自然法則である
子供は突然学校に行きたくない
それも自然法則であると思ってください
異常ではありませんよ
子供は登校を拒否したら
だから皆様に問題解決できませんよ
自然法則です 連帯理論を頭に叩き込む
依存度を下げる 家族に依存することもできるだけ避けてください
家族を慈しんでください
笑顔を忘れないようにする
よく笑う すべての生命の自由を認める
誰でも不完全であることを忘れない
これよく腹が立つでしょ？失敗すると子供でも失敗すると
あれ自然法則ですよ みんな不完全だから
失敗するのは当たり前で
だから失敗しなかったらまあよかったと喜んでください
失敗したら あ そうかって
それでいいんです 奪われない幸福とは
無執着の心 信仰ではなく
理性に基づいて生きてみましょう
信仰で生きていてはダメなんです
で この鳥のように何も囚われない
無執着のように生きることなんです
はい それで話は終了です
はい どうもありがとうございます
では たちまち人の心が幸せにあふれる慈悲の実践です
瞑想ではないんです 一応これ瞑想でもあります
慈悲の言葉は頭に叩き込むんです
繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し
脳の中で絶対忘れられないように
何か考えるものが何もなくてぼけーとしている時は
慈悲が回転するとかね
だから私も本を読んだり
いろんなことをやって
何もやることなくなったら
慈悲の瞑想しているんです
寝なくちゃあかんやなと思って横になっても眠気がない時は眠気はないし
やることはないし じゃあ慈悲
ずっと慈悲の瞑想しているんです
そういう風にも頭に叩き込むんです
慈悲の気持ちは これが決して神秘的でも何でもなく
客観的な事実ですから
生命に対して それから慈悲っていうのは一言葉でまとめて言うんだけど
精密に気持ちは4種類なんです
慈悲喜捨と言うんです
で 慈の慈の意味は友情です
いわゆるみんな仲間であると
生命たるものはみんな仲間であるという友情
悲っていうのは跋扈といって
やっぱり悩んでいる人を見ると
なんかどうにかならないのかという
人の悩み苦しみはなんか放っておけない気持ち
だから一はやりやすいんですよ
しかし もっと人格的に向上して
人が苦しんでいると放っておけないでしょうにと
放っておけないでしょうにという気持ちになる 2
番目喜です 喜ですね 慈悲喜っていうのは喜び
喜びっていうのは もっと難しいんです
悲よりも どういうことかというと
人々はバンバンうまく成功していくと
なんか機嫌が悪くなるんですね
同じ同級生であっても
一人がバンバンもうどんどんどんどんもう右肩上がりで人生がうまくいくと
なんか自分が気分が悪くなってくるんですね
あれはダメです 人は成長すると成功すると喜んでほしい
それから どんな人の努力も叶ってほしいんです
だから人の努力 叶ってほしいと祈願して
叶ったらよかったなと自分が喜びを感じるんです
それで心の病気が治ります
これは喜というんですね
捨っていうのはもっと理性的になって
頭がいい人間になる まあ世の中はそんなものでしょうというふうに
すべての生命をまとめて
冷静に平等で見るというね
例えば中国と日本の問題の場合は
どのように捨で見るのかというと
日本がね 軍事力もないし
日本は戦いもしないし
経済的にも大変やばい状態にあるし
そうなってくるとね あちらこちらからいじめられるでしょうと
野生の動物の中で 一人の動物が足が動かなくなったり
走れなくなっちゃうと
周りから来て攻撃するでしょ
例えば 野生の動物の中で一匹の動物の足に怪我をしました
そうすると ハエやらいろんな虫たちが入ってきて
食うわ食うわ食うわ それで殺しちゃいますね
これがね 生命の中にあるもんだなと
それで中国にしてみれば
あまりにも巨大な国だから
情報がいい加減で 弾圧され
あれされて生きてきて
やっと何か金が手に入るようになっただけで
それでも大変苦しんでいる人々の数がすごい大きくて
すごい豊かな都会 町なんかに至っても
みんなこの あの 何ていうのは畳一畳二畳ぐらいのところでもう六人
三人ぐらい寝て仕事してるんですよ
だからそこでいきなり興奮しちゃって
腹が立って 日本のせいだと
全部自分の不幸はとね
思うのは まあこれは動物も同じことやっちゃいますよ
結局は だからそういうふうに考えると
日本が正しいか 中国が正しいか
日本が悪いか こんなことじゃなくて
やっぱりねっていうことになるんですね
人間ってそんなものだなといって
冷静さが出てくるんですね
それが写なんですね 写という漢字当てはめてますけど
その４つまとめて この実践の言葉で来ているんです
あのリーフレットない方々は手を挙げてください
配りますので で この言葉を私はまず言います
私は幸せでありますようにと自分に対して瞑想する
私の親しい人々という次のセクションで
自分と関係ある 一緒に生きているすべての人々に
慈悲を実践する 私個人的には
私の親しい人々も幸せでありますようにと言うと
私はの親しい人々は誰と思う？まあ
当然親しい人々というか
身近な人々はいるんですよ
それだけじゃなくて 日本にいるんだから
日本人みんないるんです
日本国民みんな私の親しい人々やと一緒に生活しているんだから
それで私は育てたのはスリランカという国だから
で 身近な人々はそちらにいるんだから
では スリランカの国民がみんな結構大きいんですよ
親しい人々の枠が そのように自分というのは関係ある人々に慈悲の実践をする
それからすべての生命に生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと
それが本格的な慈悲の実践なんですね
それ終わったら自分を試してみるんです
嫌いな人々も幸せでありますようにと
そうすると気持ち悪くなったりするかもしれませんだけど
頑張ってください 嫌いな人っていうのは面白いんですよ
親しい人々なんです でなきゃ嫌いにならないでしょ
何か関係ある人なんです
だから嫌いな人はもう幸せでありますように
嫌っている人々も幸せでありますようにと
完璧な無差別 無条件 無制限の慈悲を実践する
それから言葉を説明します
1は幸せでありますように
それは慈悲喜捨の慈 メッターの実践です
2行目は悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
これは慈悲の悲なんです
放っておけない気持ち
それから願い事が叶えられますように
3番目の行 人の願い事叶ったら
その人すごく楽しいでしょ？で
喜なんです 人が喜んでほしい
生命は喜んでほしいという
慈悲喜捨の喜 捨はこちら仏教だから悟りの光が現れますようにとしています
仏教からその瞑想を外したければ
宗教は嫌だと思うならば
智慧が現れますようにと
理性が現れますようにと言えば構わない
悟りの光というのは智慧の同義語なんです
みんな 悟りに出したら OKですからね
そういうことで 慈悲喜捨に合わせて言葉使ってやります
では まあ時間的にもギリギリになってますので始まりましょう
で じゃあテキストを見ながら
まず一回一緒に読み上げてみましょう
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み 苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
と二回繰り返しましょう
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み 苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み 苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
はい これから目を閉じて
心の中で私は幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますように
と素直に念じてください
はい 次 この私はという枠を伸ばしましょう
私の両親 家族 子供 親戚
友人 会社の仲間 知り合い
あらゆる関係ある人々
みんな私というところに入れてください
私という枠をドカーンと広げるんです
はい 次のセクションに行きます
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい人々の願いごとが叶えられますように
私の親しい人々にも悟りの光
現れますように 私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい人々の願い事が叶えられますように
私の親しい人々にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい人々の願い事が叶えられますように
私の親しい人々にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
これから目を閉じて 私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますようにと繰り返し
素直に正直に念じるのです
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
はい 次 もっと私ということを無限に破れてしまうまで
しまうところまで広げるんです
すべての生命が入れてもらうんです
生きているものであるならば
命あるものであるならば
皆すべてことごとく一切幸せであってほしいという気持ちになるんです
これが瞑想の本質的なもので
初心者にはちょっとなんか把握できない
ピンとこないところがあるんです
生きとし生けるものといえばどこまでかと
それ構わない どんどんどんどんその他の生命も入れることできてできてできて
私という次元が制限が破れるんです
自我がなくなるんです
やがてみんな生命やって気持ちになるんです
だからそれには繰り返し繰り返し訓練する必要あります
では始めましょう  生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるも 幸せでありますように
はい これから目を閉じて生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと
素直に真面目に念じています
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい 次 自分の心をちょっと試してみます
本当に慈悲が生まれたかないかとチェックするんです
テストですね で 点数取れなくても構わない
繰り返し繰り返し慈悲の瞑想すればいいんです
これは私の嫌いな人々も幸せでありますようにと真面目に念じるんです
それから 私を嫌っている人々も幸せでありますようにと真剣真面目に念じてみるんです
そうすると 別にという気持ちになったら当たり前でしょうと言ったらテスト合格なんです
そう言われても 私を嫌っている連中に幸せにだったら一緒にやられるんじゃないかなと思ったら
まだまだ怒りがあるんですね
まだ慈しみがないんです
まあ成長するものだから
まあじわじわとうまくいくと思います
では始まります 私の嫌いな人々も
幸せでありますように
私の嫌いな人々の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の嫌いな人々の願い事が叶えられますように
私の嫌いな人々にも悟りの光が現れますように
私を嫌っている人々も幸せでありますように
私を嫌っている人々の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私を嫌っている人々の願い事が叶えられますように
私を嫌っている人々にも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい ありがとうございます
これは慈悲の実践 慈悲の瞑想と言います
この言葉を念じることが肝心のポイントなんです
覚えてください 我々はみんなエゴイストで
自分さえ良ければ良いと思っている生命なんです
誰でも しかし 私たちは他人のことについては悪口を言うんです
あなたはとんでもないエゴイストで悪人だと
自分さえ良ければいいと思ってるんですかと
と人には指をさす しかし
正直に自分の心に聞くと
自分も同じなんです エゴイストなんです
これ やめなさいと言ったってもやめられないんです
原始脳がそうやってエゴでできているんです
原始脳に 思考能力ないんです
思考する能力は大脳皮質にあるんです
だから 見栄張る必要も威張る必要もないんです
誰でもエゴイストなんです
それで自分を痛めることもなく
他人に迷惑をかけることもなく
微妙なやり方で この脳のプログラムを新たな OS で書き換えるんです
何のことなく書き換えられます
だから この慈悲の言葉を唱えるんです
あの言葉で言葉を出して唱えるのも構わない
何人かでグループで唱えるのも構わない
一人で唱えるのも構わない
唱えないで念じることも構わない
念じることは一番一人でいるとね
結構きちんとやれます
これ 念じて念じて念じて
朝晩 朝晩 朝晩 昼とかね
休みがあったら慈悲を念じる
寝つくまで慈悲を念じる
目が覚めたら布団から立ち上げる前に
その間でも慈悲を念じながら立ち上がって布団を片付けたりする
それでやってみると まあ 1ヶ月間
2週間でもう人生は好転していますよ
楽しくてたまらんくなっちゃうんですね
やることは失敗なくうまくいく
周りが自分との関係が結構うまくいくようになっているんです
それで 1ヶ月間に1ヶ月間になってくると
本当に脳のプログラムが変え変えているんです
書き換えているんです
自分が気づいていないんです
自分のエゴがなくなっているんです
そこで偉大なる人間になっているんです
すごいでっかい人格者になっているんです
そういうことで 方法は至って簡単
念じてください それだけ
慈悲だから 私は何か福祉活動しなくちゃいかんではないかとかね
そんな義理を感じる必要はないんです
できる範囲で福祉活動していくことは当たり前でしょ
できる範囲で人の面倒を見てあげてください
そんなもんじゃないんです
もっと偉大な人格に人格者になることなんです
それで念じることです
念じて念じて 脳のプログラムを書き換えてください
大体皆様の修行次第で結構早くこの問題解決します
これで絶えない幸福が生まれていきます
絶えない楽しみが生まれていく
病気になっても楽しい
医者があんた癌ですよと宣告されてね
されても楽しいと もうそろそろ死ぬんだそうと言っても楽しい
私はこの長老たち見たんですよ
もうもうそろそろなのに
結構楽しいんですね 自分がもう死にかけているのに
我々若者をからかったり
いろいろするんです ある有名なお坊さんがこの心臓
問題で病院で集中治療室にいるんですね
で 治療する専門の医者もそのお坊さんの弟子なんですね
仏教を学んでいて 若い人で
そこでいきなり長老の心臓が止まっちゃったんですね
止まったら機械がものすごい音を出すでしょ
たら この医者がさっと飛んできて
いきなり長の胸をガンと殴ったんですね
殴ったら心臓また動いたんです
そこでその長老はそこであの若者にあのね
あんた坊主を殴っていいと思ってる？という
この死にかけてた瞬間なんですよ
あんた坊主を殴って何考えてるんですか？あの若い医者が恥ずかしくてもう返事もできなくなっちゃって
それからもう医者がお寺に来たらからかうんですね
今すごくおとなしく なんか敬虔な信者さんのようにいるんだけど
こいつは私を殴っちゃったよと
だからそういう時でも
慈悲のある人が楽しいんですよ
人生は ああ 大変だ どうしようか
あの先生 ありがとうございます
先生のおかげで命拾いしましたよとかね
ないんです そういうことで
皆さんはにもそういう人格者の生き方できます
みんなに 今日から頑張っていただきたいと思います
では 今日から皆様はお釈迦様の世界に入れてあげたんです
ブッダの世界 智慧と理性と慈しみの世界
信仰何もない 脅しは何もない
みんな 平等で理性で物事を客観的に考える世界と
優しい慈しみの世界を皆様世界に世界を皆様にできる範囲で案内していただきました
皆様 これからも幸福でありますように
幸せで生きていられますようにと祈願いたしまして終了します
どうもありがとうございます
先生 ありがとうございました
それでは最後に皆さんで配したプログラムの二枚目の回向するのを皆さんでご唱和して終了したいと思います
それでは合掌してください
回向の法僧の三宝に礼拝奉仕し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビーティヨー ヴィヴァンジャンツー サッブローゴー ウィナッソトゥ マーデーバワットワンターラーヨー スキーディーナー
ユコーバヴァー バウォトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデーヴァター サッブブッダヌバーヴェーナー サ
ダー スッティ バワントゥテー バウォトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデーヴァター サッブダンマヌバーヴェーナー
サダー スッティ バワントゥテー バウォトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデーヴァター サッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナ
ー サダー スッティ バワントゥテー アビワーダナシーリス ニッチャン ワンダー パチャイノー チャッターロー
ダンマ ワッダンティ アウィワンノー スカン バラン
アユーラーロービャサンパッティ サンガサンパッティ ネーヴェチャ アトゥ ニッバーナ サンパッティ イミナーテー サミッジャトゥ
サード サード サード どうもありがとうございます